so let's talk about the fact that if you
say anything that is remotely edgy these
days there's this deep worry that you're
going to get canceled that people online
are going to come after you and then
they'll come after your advertisers now
as it happens to us on the show all the
time people are constantly you know
beating us up this
i trend approximately once every three
weeks i think is as much as the
algorithm will allow me to trend
on twitter but at the same time uh the
real fear is that
eventually these folks will mobilize
against advertisers against paying
customers
uh and then it'll kill your business so
how do you navigate that minefield
it's really hard uh you know i i'm proud
that i don't think barcelo has ever
really been
been beholden to which way the wind is
blowing the political climate
if you have a real fan base which we do
when we've cultivated over almost two
decades it allows you to withstand
that because i know and i've known this
for a long time
if i went to our readers who have been a
lot of them for a long time said listen
we either have to cater to what the
advertisers want
where we have to be us but you may have
to pay more and we may have to come up
may buy a t-shirt pay model i know what
our crowd would say
so it does not bother me that way
because our audience is real
and we just stay true to ourselves the
second let advertisers
dictate what you do or you beholden to
them
you lose your voice you're kind of dead
so that that's been what's
allowed us to stay true um basically to
who we are
so one of the things that you've been
doing is you're out there really helping
out small businesses in a way that
nobody else is and that's been an
initiative since covet
so what gave you the idea that you were
just going to step into the breach and
you were going to just help out these
small businesses that have been
destroyed by government yeah so
it was towards i think it was around
december when i started this and
basically new york city shut down indoor
dining
again and you know as somebody who
started a business
and can certainly identify with how much
work it
i mean barcelona was my work's life i
spent 10 years before we made any money
i just couldn't imagine not having that
decision so as i'm prone to do i went on
a rant and put it on instagram
uh and then somebody challenged me like
hey big mouth
instead of just talking about it why you
do something about it and that was the
initiative like all right
we like to control when we do charity
which we've done a lot of
because i don't necessarily trust
everybody that the money is getting
directly to who it needs so we came up
with the barstool fund
i put 500 000 of my own money in
solicited donations from
people i know who may be wealthy
whatever tom brady's of the world aaron
rodgers whoever i may
have been lucky enough to you know form
relationships and to our readers said
hey
we're doing this if you guys have money
to donate any amount helps
and then we simultaneously said if
you're a business and you just need to
bridge this gap because for a lot of the
restaurants and bars it was all small
business but a lot of the restaurant
industry
they just need warm weather you know
they need to be able to open outside and
get things going
solicit uh send in a reason what you
need and we'll try to help as many
people as we can
so i think we raised about 40 million
dollars and helped countless businesses
we started doing face time videos by
accident basically the first company we
helped
the girl who's liz gonzalez who who
helps go through the emails and
submissions she's like this person
specifically said they're a huge fan of
you dave
just surprise him with a call so i did
and when we gave him the money their
reaction was so overwhelming
um that i knew we had to capture it
moving forward because that would drive
the donations
and then it just kind of took off and
you know
it was one of those things it's so
obvious that small business was dying
because of covid and that nothing was
being done to help them
it was just common sense but once you
actually
see the people and just it's everyday
like americans and how much it meant to
get
it could be ten thousand dollars like
that's what they needed just to get over
the hump
it that's what drove it and in a weird
way
there's so much crap that was going on
in the country and has been for a little
bit
this is something that everybody should
have been
behind no matter what because it's just
it didn't matter if you're a democrat
republican if a small business owner
we're just helping you get through this
thing so it was finally i think
something that had a positive message
and
even though a lot of people don't like
me even the people who didn't like me
got quiet for a little bit because
they they'd wait how do you argue with
that exactly yeah right
i mean you personally helped out one of
the uh one of the
my my favorite kosher restaurant in
chicago and i saw that online i was like
yeah kenny kenny over there excellent
excellent italian beef
it says that that was really i mean it
was cool to see and i know that i can't
again you couldn't find a single person
who was anti it did speak to i think uh
some broader trends with with the
treatment of small business in the
country
i mean you started a business out of
nothing we started a business
out of nothing and it seemed like for a
lot of people who were stumping in favor
of we need to shut everything down and
we need to keep it shut down forever
there are people now who are saying
we need to keep everything shut down
forever that they just don't understand
how small businesses operate or what it
means to actually put your life's work
into a small business so then it's like
okay well you lost your business you
just go start a business next year it's
like well that's not how businesses
work at all correct and and i said in my
rant
i do believe this obviously it's easier
said than done but if you told me after
10 years
cove is going to hit and i lose what i
built
i would have been like i'm gonna risk my
life trying to save this to me this is i
don't want to go work for somebody else
i can't really start over like you said
it's not that easy this is my life's
work
i've poured everything into it i want
the chance to save it
and i said that from the beginning with
covet and i you know as it developed or
whatnot it's not taking
anything away from how serious it is or
isn't
but i couldn't stand not letting a
business owner
decide how they want to handle their
future and frankly in like a restaurant
i know kovid's there if i want to go
into the restaurant that's up to me
that's how i felt about it
but i just to not give these people
let them control their own destiny after
some of these businesses we
were around for 40 years grandfathers
generally it's it was insane to me it
remains
insane to me well unless you want to
give money
which we weren't doing it you know they
weren't nothing was being done
so that combo i just never understood
well so
what you're talking about in terms of
personal autonomy you can see why
conservatives might be
uh a hundred percent i mean there's a
there's a very conservative idea that
basically listen you get to make your
own choices in life you want to go into
that restaurant and risk over because
you feel like eating there
go ahead that would be that that's it
that's a you thing and if you want to
keep your business running then then
you know go for it so there is no doubt
that there's things that i'll say that
will be conservative
um i have some on the other side i want
to hear well super socially liberal
so like anything on the social aspect of
it
i'm generally in favor like you know gay
gay marriage and things like that all
for it all let people if it doesn't
affect me do whatever you want you're a
libertarian
i am a libertarian that's exactly what i
am uh yeah socially liberal financially
conservative so that's where i land
yeah join the club man i mean well to be
honest that's what i'm saying i think
normal people are like that's how i look
at it uh our libertarians mo
there's a lot more commonalities and
even like an issue which i don't like to
wade into like
black lives matter for for example i
think there's a ton of credibility
to how african americans are trading
this country you look at the capital
i think if those are all black people
who are rushing the capital they would
have gotten shot like
i believe that my heart so there's
racism here now
do i think blm got taken advantage of
there's issues like well
i think we're going a little too far
with it yeah so nothing says
like black and white no pun intended
there as it seems so
unfortunately i think a lot gets
politicized and
you know things that we should be
getting along on we end up
not but there's no doubt libertarian if
i identified would be what it is
so one aspect of that libertarianism is
obviously you have an app now that's a
sports gambling app yep
and uh and it's getting approved what
state by state how does this process
actually work
so yeah sports gambling exactly like
weed uh marijuana
it it used to be illegal everywhere
except vegas
and they overturned whatever statute
that was and said this is now a state
issue
so each state decides whether they want
to allow it
and how it will be handled and things of
that nature
it's getting passed quickly because the
states need money because of cover and
all that
so uh we are involved in this and as
somebody who grew up loving gambling
so it's like my dream thing to be
involved in so currently
if you went we have barcelona sports
book it's legal in
michigan it's legal in illinois and it's
legal in pennsylvania
and soon probably like eight more states
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show sunday special if you
did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all our future
content